ayant des parents issus de l'immigration
européenne les valeurs du Mouvement
Démocrate ont naturellement raisonné en
[Musique]
moi je m'appelle Céline Lewandowski j'ai
22 ans et je suis actuellement la
nouvelle présidente de la région cent de
Loire des Jeunes Démocrates je suis
actuellement en Master 2 à la Sorbonne
en histoire moderne mais je suis aussi
collaboratrice parlementaire à
l'Assemblée nationale pour Mathilde
déjonkerer député de loircher donc j'ai
fait une double lissence his sociologie
à l'université de tour et j'ai rencontré
Mathilde desjonkerer à la ville de
bejency lors d'un travail saisonnier où
elle était directrice du pôle culturel
patrimoine et tourisme c'est mathil
déjonkerer qui m'a fait découvrir les
valeurs du Mouvement Démocrate notamment
l'humanisme l'Europe et la ruralité et
c'est pourquoi j'ai voulu m'engager au
sein des Jeunes Démocrates et notamment
en région centre B deeloire donc c'est
une région qui me tient particulièrement
à cœur puisque j'étudie l'histoire
moderne et particulièrement cette région
au niveau du tourisme de la culture de
la gastronomie aussi qui est peu connu
ayant des parents issu de l'immigration
européenne les valeurs du Mouvement
Démocrate ont naturellement raisonné en
[Musique]
moi